even as summer reaches its height those
struggling with bills are plumbing new
depths
people are really are panicking people
are often kind of in quite they're in a
place of crisis in the last two years
cheltenham food bank has grown from one
site to four
and in the last three months they've
introduced packs specifically for people
unable to heat their meals i've spoken
to four families who have absolutely
nothing on the gas and electric like
nothing they can't cook they can't
charge a phone they can't turn the light
on like it's out sarah says she's spoken
to parents forced to choose between
bathing their children or cooking them
dinner how are you feeling
um
a bit overwhelmed a bit scared by it um
it feels like we're on the edge of a
cliff and no one wants to fall off the
cliff
[Music]
the energy company bosses tasked with
helping to avert this crisis was
summoned to number 10 today
but during this awkward interregnum
boris johnson has conceded we'll have to
wait weeks for his successor to decide
on further support
was it a constructive meeting with the
chancellor and business secretary
while the boss of eon was tight-lipped
the regulator signaled he understands
the gravity of this situation everyone
too
the situation we're really extremely
seriously thank you what do you make of
gordon brown's
comments calling for nationalizing
energy companies that can't lower their
bills so it's not something i want to
cover right now that's probably a matter
for politicians rather than the
regulator
on the surface it may seem money flows
freely in cheltenham a leafy marginal
conservative seat
but people we spoke to are sensing a
shift we're saying a lot of the time
with my mum because i can't really
afford the energy bills at home i got
four year refugees from ukraine with me
so my energy bill is going to soar
government just sitting on iran is doing
nothing it seems highly likely that the
next prime minister will eventually
announce something whether it's further
direct financial support tax cuts
extending the levy on oil and gas
profits or something more radical as
gordon brown has suggested and yet the
frustration here is that crisis seems to
have already started and yet still we're
forced to wait
arriving at tonight's hustings in the
town rishi tsunak and liz trust know
whoever wins will need to move fast on
this issue
because if there are already problems in
summer just wait until winter bites joe
pike sky news cheltenham